[Musique]
là vous venez d'entendre quelques
petites notes jouées à la sangha c'est
un instrument traditionnel originaires
d'afrique et ici à musique en fête le
musée des musiques traditionnelles et
bien il y en a des centaines et des
centaines à découvrir venez on vous
emmène
un instrument à percussion qu'il faut
secouer pour faire sortir les notes des
tubes de bambou originaire de l'île de
java l'oncle hung est exposée ici en
version xxl gabin tombe de le prendre en
main
[Musique]
c'est assez facile faut tirer sur des
cordes et ça fait de la musique donc oui
ça va il ya plusieurs sont la basse et
les plus aigus jusqu'aux plus graves et
après ça fait une belle mélodie si on
arrive à les mettre ensemble tu sais
jouer toi tu devras ce morceau là bas je
sais pas trop je tire sur des cordes au
hasard
ses compositions instrumentales permette
non initiés de jouer des sons agréables
à l'oreille et le résultat est
surprenant pour gabin plutôt habitué à
jouer de la guitare
[Musique]
dans la nef musicale les visiteurs sont
invités à tester bien sûr mais aussi à
comprendre le fonctionnement des
instruments expliqué par adeline la
directrice du musée tous les types de
bambou sont accordés note par note est
une peinture un ses passes il y as posté
note jusqu'à 10 à 12 types de bambou
pour faire ça
surtout que c'est fait à la main et à
l'oreille
à l'aise
à l'étagé supérieur c'est une incitation
au voyage les instruments sont rangés
par continent plus de 600 pièces toutes
des cadeaux faits par les groupes qui
participent chaque année au festival de
danses et musiques traditionnelles de
montoir
depuis 1973 ce festival existe dès le
10ème anniversaire il y avait une telle
somme d'instruments fallait bien faire
quelque chose c'était des témoignages
culturelles du monde entier je dis
parfois à mes visiteurs ici bat le coeur
du monde à musique en fête
et la musique bat aussi dans le coeur
des visiteurs
c'est là qu'on regrette de ne pas avoir
appris à jouer parce que ça c'est un
moyen de communication tellement
important riche
en moyens de voyager aussi aux quatre
coins du monde en se baladant simplement
dans cet antre musicale située à 20
minutes donnant donnant
jean-françois on vient de découvrir
votre musée consacré aux musiques
traditionnelles musiques en fête et vous
c'est une histoire qui dure oui
effectivement c'est l'histoire qui est
né en 1997 quand on a fait l'état des
lieux de
tous les instruments des costumes qu'on
avait en stock que nous offrait les
groupes depuis le début du festival en
1973 on s'est dit c'est plus possible de
là il faut faire quelque chose et il
faut d'abord le montrer parce que ça
paiera 10 le festival et ensuite on
pouvait plus en accueillir de nouveau
donc nse musée des musiques du monde en
1997 à dire 25 ans après la création du
festival vous parlez des instruments et
des cautions ont dans la face à nous ils
viennent d'où cela par exemple alors ici
on est face à une exposition de masques
de carnaval de la république dominicaine
c'est une exposition qui est venu tout
spécialement en france l'année passée
qui n'a pas pu être exposé jusqu ici à
cause du coup lui de tous les problèmes
que vous connaissez eh bien parfois nous
en avons hérité avec beaucoup de plaisir
ce musée il vous tient énormément à
coeur je le vois même dans la visite qui
a eu c'est vraiment votre bébé à vous
aussi oui bah bien sûr c'est normal on
s'est beaucoup investie c est pour nous
ça représente beaucoup de choses parce
que ce sont des cadeaux d'amis en grande
partie est
bon c'est une news ont fait l'honneur de
nous les confier je pense que nous de
notre de notre côté on doit absolument
démontrer les préserver en faire
profiter un maximum de public il vous
faudrait une pièce plus grande en fait
pour exposer les costumes qui a en plus
dans votre collection oui en fait le
problème il est là c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de costumes et des costumes
très intéressant qui sont soudés ou ce
qu'ils dorment sous des housses mais on
attend que voulez vous le bon vouloir
des collectivités pour créer 7
cet espace consacré aux costumes et
éthiques mais en sachant qu'il ya déjà
des collectivités qui se sont
mode qui sont motivés et qu'ils sont
prêts nous avait on attend simplement un
coup de pouce au démarrage y a plus qu'à
croiser les doigts oui très fort parce
que ça fait 14 ans pour battre bon et
puis si vous voulez vivre en fait ces
musiques traditionnelles pas forcément
pendant le festival met tout le long de
l'année et bien c'est ici qu'il faut
venir à musique en fête absolument et on
vous accueillera avec beaucoup de
plaisir